hey guys and welcome back to the channel
sorry for the delay on my end making new
videos I've been traveling a little bit
uh just like back home for the week and
uh just had a ton of errands my ceiling
is leaking a bunch of water got all over
my tech and I almost flipped a so
yeah stupid delays stuff like that
anyways let's go ahead and get into this
video
all right so today we're going to be
talking about SQL databases so just
before I really get into things as a
quick 30 second cautionary rant please
skip over this if you don't care I am
going to make a lot of generalizations
about both MySQL and postgres in this
video and the truth is these are
technologies that are open source
they're constantly changing and pretty
much anything I say about them is
pretty much falsifiable like
objectively even though I'm going to say
certain things about these Technologies
they change literally all the time and
in addition to that people are just
adding garbage features to them all the
time so I might say that you know you
tend to do one certain type of
replication with them but the truth of
the matter is probably all different
types are supported because they're open
source and some Bozo at some point in
time was like I want to do later list
replication with my sequel don't know
why you would but they probably did it
so let's go ahead and get into things
talk about this and get started so SQL
databases we went over these in the last
video and we know that they're good for
relational data normalized data where
you basically want to have one reference
to your piece of data and have it stay
consistent throughout all of your data
you don't want to denormalize your data
where you'd have to potentially have
multiple copies of a given right and
then that would be problematic in terms
of you know having to write to your data
multiple times you might even need
distributed transactions if you want to
guarantee correctness of all of your
data
so just as an example of that we've got
our people table we've got our
attractions table as you can see I'm
primary ID number one Jordan and then we
have three lovely ladies over here who
are all attracted to me checks out
pretty consistent with real life the
question is though and we started to
talk about this last video obviously we
want to be using a relational database
table when we have relational data that
should be normalized but are there ever
cases where we should do it even when we
don't care about having relational data
and my answer to that is yes albeit only
sometimes so let's talk about why we
would based on the architecture of both
MySQL and postgres and just other
relational databases in general so
generally speaking because SQL databases
are a little bit older than nosql ones
they were kind of the predominant type
of database from like the 1980s onwards
they tend to use slightly older
architectures and I guess that has
certain performance uh kind of
characteristics at least in theory in
practice there are all sorts of random
optimizations and edge cases that all of
these different types of databases have
implemented and so you know to actually
go and be like oh you know this thing is
going to have this many transactions per
second because it uses a b tree or an
LSM tree I won't do that I can't do that
I would be a sham if I tried to do that
but in an interview you can get away
with saying stuff like this because it
shows that you understand the concepts
so let's go ahead and do that so what
are some common features of most SQL
databases well for one they tend to be B
tree based indexes so as a quick
reminder for everyone a b tree based
index is pictured here on the right and
it's where you actually have a tree on
disk for both your reads and your rights
that you are basically directly writing
to and from in contrast to an LSM tree
and SS table based index where we have a
basically memory based tree plus a bunch
of different tables on disk reads in
theory should be a little bit faster on
the B tree because we just jump right to
our thing as opposed to an LSM tree
based table where first we check here
and then we check here and then we check
here and then we check here so again
could be better for reads could be worse
for rights in practice again tons of
software optimizations that can be done
and you would really just have to try
them out for your own setup and figure
out what is best based on benchmarking
number two single leader replication now
like I mentioned it is the case that you
can do any sort of replication with any
of these databases it just tends to be
the case that I think most people using
relational databases are using single
leader replication just because I don't
know that's kind of the traditional way
of doing it I feel like that's more of
like the Mantra of the relational
database system feel free to call me out
on this but uh no one ever does so here
we are I'm gonna say it anyway
single leader replication
multi-leader replication this guy can
have right conflicts which we can deal
with using things like version vectors
or crdts but at the end of the day that
doesn't necessarily get rid of the
conflicts it just gives us a way of
ensuring that all of our databases agree
on the result it doesn't necessarily
make the result correct whereas single
leader replication we've got basically
one bottleneck a single database that
all the rights have to go through and
thus we can achieve an ordering on our
rights finally we have configurable
isolation levels now a lot of nosql
databases and we'll touch upon this in
the next few videos don't necessarily
give you the ability to have fully acid
compliant transactions they're not
necessarily completely isolated and we
can't necessarily establish an ordering
over all of them as if they're running
on one thread on the other hand for
these relational databases you do at
least have the option to do that however
it does come at a performance cost
obviously because it involves either
locking or serializable snapshot
isolation both of which we will talk
about right now out so this is kind of
the main difference that I've decided to
pick out between my Sequel and postgres
which is that yeah obviously you can go
look at the feature sets of all of them
then you'll see that postgres has like a
few more supported index types but I'm
really trying to think of like the core
functionality of the two systems here
and you know this was kind of the main
one that I picked out their indexes are
generally similar MySQL uses nodb I
don't think postgres does but uh yeah I
picked this out sorry you're gonna have
to listen to me here so for my sequel we
use two-phase locking and two-phase
locking is where basically every single
row has locks in order to read a row in
a transaction that's read only you can
grab the lock in a shared mode but in
order to write you have to get it in an
exclusive mode and so that makes reads a
little bit more optimized than rights
that being said you still do have to
grab a lot of locks at the end of the
day and with all of those locks we can
have transactions that grab the same set
of blocks thus causing Deadlocks which
we would have to get rid of and hurt our
performance even more on the other hand
postgres uses serializable snapshot
isolation which is a bit newer of a
technology I should also mention that I
think MySQL is starting to get into this
as well but like again you know these
feature sets change all the time if
you're watching this video in a year
from now who knows how true any of this
will be so that's why I make these
sweeping generalizations which could be
wrong but either way it serves as a good
case study for our point so postgres
uses SSI which I have a dedicated video
on this if you need more information on
it but the overall summary is that
transactions will read from a data
snapshot and of course if a transaction
reads a value from a given snapshot that
by the time it's trying to commit has
since been modified by a second
transaction we need to roll back the
original and so there are going to be
some transactions that get rolled back
but this is ultimately a form of OCC
which is optimistic concurrency control
because we're not locking assuming that
everything can go wrong we're acting as
if nothing can go wrong and then when it
does we roll back
okay so what are the conclusions of
using SQL databases well I did click the
you guys in the sense that you know
mainly I kind of wanted to just talk
about SQL databases and I figured my SQL
versus postgres would be a better title
but the point is in addition to needing
normalized data which is a really good
use case for when you want a SQL
database another good use case is when
you just need data that has to be
correct if you need acid compliant
transactions because otherwise you could
have conflicting rights and race
conditions then you basically need to
use the SQL database most of the nosql
ones don't really support these
isolation levels again I kind of say
that take that with a grain of salt
because they can all eventually
Implement them who knows what's going to
happen
that being said when you do have to
choose between those two SQL databases
which are mainly MySQL and postgres I
feel like those are the two most popular
open source ones even though postgres
does use SSI if there are potentially a
lot of kind of conflicting transactions
to be had then that means you're going
to be doing a lot of rollbacks which
ultimately might be more costly than
just locking pessimistically so that is
something to keep in mind you have to
think about your actual data use case if
you're like building a counter and
that's the only thing your database is
doing and so every single thing is like
a read modify update cycle where those
two rights are overlapping with one
another then maybe you'd actually just
be better off with locking than rolling
back 90 of your rights so in that case
pessimistic locking could actually be
better but hopefully this makes sense
guys generally yeah if you care about
data correctness you probably want
single leader replication you probably
want acid transactions and then at that
point a SQL database mostly makes sense
the B tree versus lsm3 thing is a little
bit different I guess that's more of
like whether you care about prioritizing
first rights But ultimately it is still
something to think about too anyways
guys have a great rest of the weekend I
will see you in the next one and looking
forward to it